as our institutions of power move ever
more toward critical race theory
americans are fighting back and winning
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data
expressvpn.com ben we'll get to all the
news in just
one moment first let's be clear about
this you are spending too much money on
your cell phone bill how do i know this
because if you're not with pure talk usa
you are definitely spending too much
money
on your cell phone bill which is why
another thousand of you my
extraordinarily wise listeners
have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to pure talk
over the past couple of months
so here's the question what are the rest
of you waiting for if you're with att or
verizon or t-mobile your family
could save over 800 a year just by
switching over
to puretalk you get the same great
coverage because they use the exact same
towers as one of the big carriers you
can even keep your phone and your number
but you will be saving a fortune by the
way puretalk is the top-rated wireless
company by consumer affairs
with the absolute best customer service
team based right here in america if this
sounds good it gets even better right
now
get unlimited talk text six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on the data they're not going to
charge you for it
grab your mobile phone dial dialpound250
say ben shapiro when you do
you'll save 50 off your very first month
dial pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
to get started puretalk is simply
smarter wireless a lot of the other big
cell phone providers they will
tell you what you are getting and then
they really won't tell you they're sort
of obscure it because they're actually
paying for their marketing campaigns and
paying for their
stores the the actual brick and mortar
stores not so with pure talk usa you
know exactly what you're getting and
what you're getting is what you need
for less money pure talk simply smarter
wireless dial pound two five zero say
ben shapiro to get started
today alrighty so you may have noticed
that critical race theory has become the
topic of the day
and the media are fighting mad about it
they are very very angry about this
as we'll discuss critical race theory
has been infiltrating our institutions
for
literally decades and it is the ideology
that has taken over most of our major
institutions this is why we saw the
specter last week
of an admiral in the united states navy
explaining why he had recommended
that sailors be reading ibram x candy
who's one of the great race grifters and
racists of our time
it's the reason why there are
corporations all over america
training their workers that if they are
white they suffer
from inevitable whiteness and this
inevitable whiteness
is in fact a symptom of discrimination
it's like to do the work
do the work in order to be properly woke
and in order to
properly address their own flaws these
inherent flaws in them
not they've done anything bad in their
life but because of their whiteness they
are bad this is why you see corporations
giving money to things like gibbermex
kennedy center
that's why you see jack dorsey of
twitter giving 10 million dollars to
upper mexican center for anti-racist
research
which today has produced no actual
research it's the reason
why you see the media consistently using
the language of crt
always using the language of equity
rather than the language of equality the
language of equality
is in the declaration of independence
it's in the constitution the language of
equity is not because equity
is a mush term that in modern parlance
has come to mean
equal outcome rather than actual
fairness
by fairness typically speaking you go
back to the ancients the idea is
fairness is you get what you deserve
right your action results in particular
results
and this would be equity this would be
justice that is not what the modern
definition of equity means the modern
definition of equity means that no
matter what your action
the outcome should always be the same
because after all the system is rigged
against you and failure is just a
symptom
that the system is rigged against you
the basic tenets of critical race theory
have in fact been watered down and then
spread like manure
all the way through most of our major
institutions from corporate america to
the media to academia where it began
and certainly into the halls of
government and what you see from the
media is an unwillingness to confront
this
or a willingness to champion it the
media's reaction on this has been
utterly irresponsible because of course
they are proponents
of crt crt is not merely a legal theory
it started off as legal theory sort of
like intersectionality started off as a
legal theory
and then it became an actual activist
point
this happens in politics all the time by
the way there are kind of highfalutin
theories
and then they are kind of dehydrated and
dehydrated more
and dehydrated more to the point where
they become a pill and then all you do
is you take the pill and now you have
become
sort of an advocate for that ideology
and the game that people like to play
is that after people take that pill and
get the inevitable results of that pill
then they say well you know that really
has nothing to do with the original
ideology right this is just
boiling down to that but here is the
reality the reality is that crt
was corrupt and wrong in its first
instance and that the
logical progression of crt what we are
seeing now is in fact connected
to critical race theory so i'm going to
start today
by going through what exactly critical
race theory is in the words of some of
the creators of critical race theory
and then we're going to show you how the
media boil this down and how terrible it
is
for america because they are actively
spreading this stuff now the reason that
i'm bringing this up
is because yesterday i was browsing in
advance of the show
and i noticed that the front page of the
washington post like the front page of
the washington post
had this video on it okay and the the
title on the video it's from some new
show they call the lily
is what is white racial identity and why
is it important
and the first thing that occurred to me
when i saw this by the way
is that video that was put out by the
comedian
uh the i'm trying to remember his name
ryan something
that video in which it showed a woke
person and a racist person and it turns
out they agreed on everything
okay because how else do you get a
headline from the washington post that
says what
is white racial identity and why is it
important is this the very top of the
washington post page
it was connected to a five minute video
about
basically why you are if you are white
you're inevitably guilty
and you're responsible for evil citizen
evil systems that are promulgated
throughout american life
and that result in inequity the video is
amazing
so we're going to start before we get to
the video with an explanation of what
crt is and then you'll see
how it has been basically rebranded
repackaged gussied up
and then just shoved in your face via
places like the washington post
okay so here are the basic tenets of
critical race theory
and richard delgado and gene stefanczek
were two of the founders of critical
race theory in the late 1970s
okay so what i'm about to quote is from
their book critical race theory and
introduction and the reason i'm doing
this is because one of the games that
the media love to play
is when you say critical race theory
they will say what do you even mean by
critical race theory what i mean is
exactly what the founders of critical
race theory are saying how about that
and what i mean by critical race theory
is exactly what critical race theory is
i don't mean what the media say that it
is because they lie about it
i don't mean what people who don't know
a critical race theory say that it is
say that it is a critical race theory
was like assigned reading when i was at
harvard law school
this was a well-respected branch of
thought at harvard law school when i was
there and that was all the way back in
2007 i graduated
and so here is some of what they say
delgado and stefanczyk
in critical race theory and introduction
quote although critical race theory
began as a movement in the law
it has rapidly spread beyond that
discipline okay so this gives the lie
that you'll sometimes hear from people
in the media well you know it was just a
legal way of looking at things it really
has nothing to do with the activism we
see it wrong
okay even the founders of that movement
understand that it is a movement it
start
like most things in life it started as
an academic theory and then
eventually it turned into a political
activist movement and marxism originally
started as an academic theory and then
it turned into a politically activist
movement that resulted in the slaughter
of you know 100 million people okay so
it turns out a lot of ideological
movements
eventually turn out to be practical
political movement
so here's what they write although
critical race theory began as a movement
in the law it has
rapidly spread beyond that discipline
today many in the field of education
consider themselves critical race
theorists
who use crt's ideas to understand issues
of social of school discipline and
hierarchy
tracking controversies over curriculum
and history an iq and achievement
testing
political scientists ponder voting
strategies coined by critical race
theorists
ethnic studies courses often include a
unit on critical race theory and
american studies departments teach
material on critical white studies
developed by crt writers
unlike some academic disciplines
critical race theory contains an
activist
dimension again this is the founders
admitting this is an activist ideology
it not only tries to understand our
social situation but to change it
it sets out not only to ascertain how
society organizes itself along racial
lines and hierarchies
but to transform it for the better i
remember not me saying it
these are the founders of critical race
theory saying this it is an activist
ideology
designed to tear away at the systems of
the united states
and they're bragging that it has spread
into every major discipline in the
united states so it's not the right
disclaiming this is not some sort of
chimera it's not a figment of our
imagination
the people who founded it brag openly
about how this ideology has spread
through our institutions everything from
testing philosophy with regard to
educational
movements to how people vote right all
of that has been bled
in with regard to crt so what are the
principles of critical race theory
so there are essentially four laid out
by delgado and stefanczyk
in this particular book there are two
that pretty much everybody agrees on and
there are two that are kind of argued
about because they're in direct conflict
with one another
it's the first two that everybody agrees
about our quote first
that racism is ordinary not aberrational
normal science the usual way society
does business the common everyday
experience of most people of color in
this country
right so that means that you are racist
even if you don't know
you're racist because the systems are
racist and you are shaped by the systems
racism is not an aberration you can't
point to that guy over there and say ah
that guy's a racist because
he says racist stuff no that's not how
racism is defined
racism is just the water in which we
swim racism is the air that we breathe
everything that surrounds us the
mesmatic substances that surround us
and in which we live our lives those are
where racism lives
racism is ordinary the way that
breathing air is ordinary and drinking
water is ordinary
right it's normal science second most
would agree that our system of white
over color ascendancy serves important
purposes
both psychic and material the first
feature ordinariness
means that racism is difficult to cure
or address okay this is one of the key
tenets of critical race theory it's very
very difficult to fight racism
very difficult now the reason they say
this is not because they actually want
to fight racism
the reason they say this is because
their entire proposition
is that you cannot fight racism as an
individual level if you call out a
racist incident you have not helped
fight racism
the only way to fight racism is to
search within your own heart and even
then
it's really not within your own heart
because you may have nothing but good
intentions you really have to search
inside your own adherence to your
environment right you have to search
inside your own adherence to american
systems
everything must be leveled everything
must be torn out by the roots
that's how you fight racism and this is
central to their theory
it means that racism is difficult to
cure or address colorblind or formal
conceptions of equality
expressed in rules that insist only on
treatment that is the same across the
board can thus remedy only the most
blatant forms
of discrimination such as mortgage
redlining or the refusal to hire a black
phd
rather than a white high school dropout
that do stand out and attract our
attention
and so here is where we immediately
start sliding into if there is no equal
outcome then some sort of deep inequity
has been done right they're saying that
if you fight racism by pointing out that
a black phd should get the math job
over the white high school dropout
that's not actually fighting racism it
doesn't do any good because racism is
hard to fight and that would be easy
that's one of the games that the crt
advocates like to play is refusal to
define terms they like to be
deliberately vague the vaguer they are
the more they can claim that you are
failing to achieve their purposes
see when you give people the idea that
they get to go ghost hunting that
basically the way you fight racism
is not to fight actual on-the-ground
racism it's to actually ghost hunt
and no matter what they do you can say
they've not achieved it no matter what
racism they have thought no matter what
racism they oppose you can say well it
doesn't matter
because you see it's very difficult to
fight racism and you haven't
internalized that battle yet
okay this is why critical race theory in
essence is just a cult
you're supposed to follow whatever the
cult leaders tell you and if you don't
follow what the cult leaders tell you
they will tell you that you have not
been sufficiently
loyal to the cause of anti-racism turn
and get to more from the authors of
critical race theory and i'm quoting the
people who write this stuff
i'm not making it up i'm quoting it to
you because and the reason i'm doing
this again is because the media lie
and they say that if you are critical of
critical race theories because you
haven't done the reading
okay i'm reading you the reading so now
you've done the reading i'll get to that
in just one second first
let's talk about protecting your homes
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting my home it matters to me
if somebody stops by or something is
going on outdoors around the house ring
will let me know it's peace of mind
anytime knowing that my home is
protected at my house i can keep an eye
on every corner of the house with rings
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
i'll tell you this comes in handy like
every single day so i have three kids
they're constantly running around my
house
right the little one you know because
she's a small child she's like a year
and a half old
she's just learned to walk she's
constantly bumping into things if i lose
her for like half a second
she might be doing something to get
herself in trouble i rely on my ring
devices to let me know where she is at
all times because if i look away for one
second she might be gone
this is why i love rings get ring alarm
for yourself go to ring.com forward
slash men it is the perfect way to start
your ring
experience besides ring being a powerful
asset for my home ring is also an
affordable
home home security system you can easily
install yourself it's never been more
important to be able to see who's there
or what's happening anytime around the
house
inside or outside and i can see it all
in one simple app
that's right with ring my family and i
can keep an eye on our home no matter
where we are right from our phone
how great to know you're not going to
miss a visitor with rings hassle free
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
and know when those packages are
delivered and keep an eye on your kids
start protecting your home today with
ring alarm go to ring.com
ben get your ring alarm security kit
today build the system that's right for
your home have it up and running in just
minutes that's ring.com
again ring.com go check them out
right now alrighty so
richard delgado and gene stefancek
continue in critical race theory and
introduction so
we've already established a few key
principles here okay one racism is
ordinary not aboriginal two
white over color ascendancy serves
important purposes okay what they say
here
is that this second principle white over
color ascendancy serves important
purpose
purposes this actually
is deeply tied into policy they say this
second feature sometimes called
interest convergence or material
determinism as a further dimension
because racism advances the interests of
both white elites
material or materially and working-class
people psychically
large segments of society have little
incentive to eradicate it okay so the
idea here is that racism again is all
around you
and it serves you you may think that
you're against racism you're not
you're happy about racism because if
you're an elite it serves you materially
the system serves you
as an elite the system serves you the
system is racist therefore you are
racist in upholding the system if you
are a poor white person
you are still privileged by the system
because you psychically get to look at
all these people of color and say those
people of color are less than i am
and therefore i have more common cause
with the white elite than i do
with the people who are of my own class
you may notice the marxist tinge here
right because now we're talking about
class differentiation and why really
people should have class solidarity
rather than racial solidarity
you can see that the marxist dimension
has started to slip in here because as
we'll explain in just a second
critical race theory isn't a neo marxist
movement is an offshoot of critical
theory which is
in and of itself a marxist movement okay
so what are the effects of this okay so
derek bell who's again in a major
critical race theorist will get more on
him in a second
he had a shocking proposal the brown
versus board of education for example
right that is one of the great
anti-racist moments in american history
with an actual supreme court decision
saying that under the constitution of
the united states it is illegal
for blacks and whites to be forced into
separate schools
derek bell says that this just
promulgated more racism
he says that the brown versus board of
education considered a great triumph of
civil rights
litigation may have resulted more from
the self-interest of elite whites
than a desire to help blacks okay so
these are the first two themes and these
are the ones that everybody kind of
agrees on one is that racism is ordinary
not aberrational
and the second is that that ordinariness
serves important psychic and material
purposes for white people
right your whiteness makes you enjoy the
racism of the system
okay then we get to two principles of
crt that are sort of in conflict with
one another
and when i say sort of i mean almost
directly in opposition to one another
according to delgado and stephanie a
third theme of critical race theory the
social construction thesis
holds that race and races are products
of social thought and relations
not objective inherent or fixed they
correspond to no biological or genetic
reality
rather races are categories that so
society invents manipulates or retires
when convenient okay so then you might
say okay well that sounds more like
you know the martin luther king thing
okay so if race is a social construction
then we really should attempt to see
beyond race we should see individuals as
individuals
okay but no this is not what critical
race theorists argue instead they argue
that systems of power are racist
and they have made up race as a social
construct in order
to damn other people but the way that
you get beyond that is not by seeing
beyond race
the way that you get beyond that is by
embracing race okay which brings us to
the fourth thesis which is a direct
conflict
thesis the fourth thesis is the notion
of a unique voice of color
coexisting in someone uneasy tension
with anti-essentialism the voice of
color thesis holds that because of their
different histories and experiences with
oppression
black indian asian and latino writers
and thinkers may be able to communicate
to their white counterparts matters that
the whites are unlikely to know
minority status in other words brings
with it a presumed competence to speak
about race and racism
the legal storytelling movement urges
black and brown writers to recount their
experiences with racism and legal system
and to apply their own unique
perspectives to assess laws master
narratives
this is where you get into the
superiority of the of the perspective
of people of color right white people
can't talk about this stuff they're
presumed incompetent to talk about this
stuff now you may say wait a second i
thought that race was a social construct
ah but no because in essence this fourth
thesis
is more important than the third thesis
there's racial essentialism
if you are white you suffer from
whiteness if you're a person of color
you have a presumed superiority to speak
about racism and we must listen to your
perspectives
on the system now all of this is the
outgrowth of critical theory critical
theory is a branch of thought that began
in the early 20th century with something
called the frankfurt school the
frankfurt school posited basically that
systems
of power and hierarchy throughout the
world
were in fact covers for discrimination
and cruelty
and thus we had to be super critical
about all of those systems of power
it was a marxist theory that basically
said that
everything bad in nazi germany was a
product of capitalism everything
america the frankfurt theorists actually
openly said that america in the 1950s
was proto-fascist that was going to lead
to nazi germany which is of course
insane
they were marxist of course they
believed that a critical theory
is is a sort of neo-marxist movement in
which power defines everything
right which as you can see bled the only
difference between sort of critical
theory and critical race theory
you can see the similarity in the names
is the word race instead of saying
that all the systems of power are
created in order to help the upper class
which is sort of a critical theory
posits
critical race theory posits that all of
the systems of power were created in
order to help people of specific races
okay which is why there is pretty heavy
crossovers so derek bell who i mentioned
earlier again one of the
founders of critical race theory and a
man who barack obama famously
hugged in the 1980s as he was trying to
preserve his tenure at harvard law
school despite having done very little
academic work
derek bell wrote the whole liberal world
view of private rights and public
sovereignty
mediated by the rule of law needed to be
exploded
a worldview premised upon the public and
private spheres is an attractive mirage
that masks the reality of economic and
political power right so what is the end
goal of critical race theory according
people like derek bell
explode the system the end goal is to
teach everybody that they are the
products of a corrupt system
the only way to extirpate and exergate
your own whiteness
is to involve yourself in this great
task
of exploding the system ideas of private
and public rights
the idea of liberal world views
in which you have the rights of freedom
of speech or the right to own your own
property
all of these things lead to
discrimination and not not only lead to
them
spring from a desire to uphold
discrimination
this is the fundamental political theory
of critical race theory
okay so all of this is the lead up to
how the media present this stuff
okay so the way that the media present
this stuff is as a way to fight racism
so they discovered that using the term
critical race theory is actually not
particularly helpful because people look
at it and they go wait this sounds like
super stupid and racist
it sounds like you want to tear down the
most successful systems that have ever
been created
for creating the possibility of
prosperity
wealth equality right
you want to get rid of those sounds like
you want to explode those why would we
possibly listen to you so instead they
came with this new rubric and the new
rubric is
this is anti-racism so what they do is
they take critical race theories idea of
race which is that is implicit in
everything and then they say
in order to be anti-racist you have to
tear down the systems
they've shifted the definition of racism
from stuff that we all understood to be
racism namely
a belief in the superiority or
inferiority of an individual based on
their racial
characteristics they took that they
trashed it and he said no
that's not what real racism is real
racism is believing in the system
so anti-racism would be destroying the
system
so under that rubric of quote-unquote
anti-racism they've started to
infiltrate all of the major institutions
the word racism is such a powerful word
in american public life
because of the true and vicious history
of racism in the united states that if
you can hijack that word
if you can morph that word into a code
word for the system and tearing down the
system
if you can do all of that you've
achieved unbelievable things on behalf
of a left that wishes to destroy all of
those systems
in the name of some sort of greater
equity and this is exactly what the
washington post proposes to do now to
normal people who watch this stuff
it looks like gobbledygook you watch
this and you're like i don't understand
what
in the f you are talking about when we
watch this washington post video
together which again is about five
minutes long
when we watch that together and listen
to it you'll see it makes no sense
nobody bothers to define their terms
these folks sound as though they are
cult members trying to explain the cult
to other people
it sounds weird and bizarre it sounds
vague and unpractical but that is the
whole purpose the whole purpose is
in order for you to be a member of the
elect
a member of the political and
intellectual elite you
have to buy into a system it is all
about social virtue signaling
you wonder what people are learning in
colleges these days they're not learning
about american history for sure
instead what they are learning is how to
speak this language because this
is the key into the elite in modern
american society it's the key to
institutional power in american society
is the woke run the place now in just
one second we're going to go through
this video because it really is
indicative of where we are
in the debate and why there is blowback
right now well justified blowback first
let us talk about why you don't want to
go to the auto parts store
because who wants to go to the auto
parts store you're going to stand in
line for like 15 minutes then you're
going to get to the front of the line
you're going to answer a bunch of
questions then the guy behind the
counter is going to be like oh i don't
have that part in stock what if i just
order it
for you online and upcharge you by 30 or
you could just
go to the intro labs because the
interweb is a magical place go to
rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
is your odyssey and lx or an ex
and then they usually just have to order
the part online anyway because there are
so many types of cars it's impossible to
keep them all stocked
instead rockauto.com offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog's unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications prices you prefer go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available
for your car or truck right shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we
got that car fixed up the right way
rockauto.com right shapiro in there how
did you hear about xbox so they know
that we sent you okay finally this
brings us to the washington post
understanding your whiteness video it's
all about understanding your whiteness
and truly this is racist crap because as
you may have noticed the notion of
racial essentialism
that your racial characteristics define
you and define your perspective is
racism
the notion that we ought to treat you as
superior or inferior in your
outlook on the world based on your race
is in fact the classical definition of
racism
but it's now anti-racism because it's
directed against destroying the
quote-unquote racist systems okay so
this comes out as a weird bunch of
gobbledygook nonsense i'm gonna try and
translate it for you here here's the
washington post lead story yesterday
again from washington post the lily
racism racialization white body
supremacy
is not episodic it's structural remember
that there were um thousands of george
floyd before the one that you saw
your bodily response to this this horror
right is not the same thing as you
dealing with the structural aspects of
business george floyd's death became a
deeply personal and racial tragedy for
many americans
for the first time white people were
becoming aware of their whiteness and
the systemic ways that white supremacy
affects
all of us white people in particular get
aroused to get upset
say this is unjust this isn't right this
shouldn't happen
there's like an awakening that happens
and so part of their
racial identity development is seeing
that awakening what they do with it
is really the next piece of it in this
episode we're tackling
white racial identity and why
understanding your whiteness is integral
to becoming self-aware
as a white person i'm nicole ellis and
this is the new posit there for a second
alrighty so understanding your white
identity now you may have thought to
yourself i don't really have
a white identity like for me i'd be
considered white by these folks
i'm jewish my identity is many different
things but kind of in terms of ethnicity
it's more jewish because that actually
connects to how i act in the real world
and
and honestly i don't care about
ethnicity so my jewish ethnic identity
is really only tied into the fact that
as the son of a jewish mother
i am religiously jewish right by that
law but my ethnicity really has nothing
to do with it
and the idea of a general white identity
is also very weird
because the only aspect of quote-unquote
white identity
is generally in american history in
opposition to quote-unquote black
identity
or asian identity or mexican identity
but the reality is
that for the vast majority of history
and including american history
people didn't see themselves in terms of
white identity
okay they saw themselves in terms of
sort of where they came from there was
irish identity there was italian
identity there was czech identity there
was jewish identity there was russian
identity
and if you go to europe today trying to
say to an italian you have white
identity they'd be like what i'm italian
what are you talking about
like brits and italians they have
different cultural heritages
because culture is not the same as
ethnicity the attempt to cudgel
everybody
who is not a person of color into the
white identitarian category is an
awkward one
and is in fact a social construction but
for these folks like nicole ellis of the
washington post it is important that you
understand your white identity what they
mean
is they're going to cuddle you into an
identity where you are responsible for
all the evils of the world
you are responsible for the george floyd
situation
here first of all when res menachem at
the very beginning
an author when he says at the beginning
there are thousands of george floyds you
never saw
well i mean under what time context are
we talking are we talking like
the last several hundred years because
then that's true are you talking about
like the last several years the answer
of course is no
the number of black unarmed men killed
in the united states by cops
is under 20 every single year so no it's
not thousands of people or being treated
the way that george floyd was treated
okay but
again the idea is that pointing out that
incident which again was not even like
there's still no evidence it's amazing
how this has been promulgated there's
still
no evidence that was a racist incident
it was not alleged in court it was not
ledged by the federal government it's
been alleged by no one
and yet that has become the racial
incident in america despite the fact
that there's no racial animus thought
why because it's structural you've heard
that word structural
okay the idea again is that in reality
derek chauvin isn't
really according to crt even to blame
for derek shelvin's activity derek
shovin
is just an agent of the structure and
the structure is to blame
and you are both to blame for upholding
the structure and you are a symptom of
that structure because you are created
by that structure
okay let's continue at this washington
post video
[Music]
it says why is white racial identity
important i
am originally from a smaller
town in oklahoma whiteness was the
defaults and whiteness was the comfort
part of the structure of racism in the
way that it's maintained
is to keep us from recognizing that
racism is a part of
our daily lives and so it's a longer
term process
of looking at your understanding of
yourself
in the world both historically but also
contextually
the family you live in the community you
live in
and what role whiteness plays in that
so here you have a woman named kelsey
aries originally saying
that whiteness was her default and her
comfort i don't know what that's
supposed to mean
other than this is her confessing her
sins in mao's style right
she didn't know she was racist but it
was her default and her comfort
she didn't even know she didn't even
know what kind of sin she was committing
but she was
by dint of just where she lived and then
you have rebecca tobarak who is one of
these authors who was speaking before
saying that you know finding your
whiteness and discovering your own sin
is a lifelong process
that sounds very much again like cultic
language it sounds like a cult
sounds like you have to spend your
entire life cleansing yourself
of whatever the master says is your sin
you have to spend your entire it's a
lifelong process of discovering your own
whiteness
and looking within or
and what exactly are you hunting for the
answer is you're hunting for whatever i
tell you to hunt for
you're hunting for your own unconscious
racial bias that has infused the core of
your very being
and the only and if you can't uncover it
it's because you're racist obviously
right this is the perfect kafka trap if
you say well i looked inside myself and
i really don't think i'm racist
ah it's because you are so infused with
your own racism you can't even recognize
your own racism
pretty incredible stuff this nonsense
continues
the more you kind of dive into that the
more i'm really realizing how deeply
rooted
racism is and to like my everyday
thought process
no matter how much you work at that
there's still even almost more work to
be done
a living embodied anti-racist culture
does not exist
among white people white people got to
start getting together specifically
around race
wide accountability groups are really
helpful in terms of having a place to
process
having a group of people whose
responsibility
it is to call me on things or to
challenge me
we're unpacking wrong things that we've
been
taught in history class i realized
that i needed to go back and unpack
and reorganize everything that i had
learned because it was complete
okay stop for a second okay so the so
washington post recognizes
and they they suggest you should create
an accountability group this is direct
malice crap direct mouse so over the
weekend
i was reading a book about the current
what they call third revolution in china
the xi jinping revolution
and what they've done in many of their
companies is they have these sort of
political groups
where you're supposed to get together
and this has been true for decades
really since the inception of maoism but
now it's sort of moved into the
corporate sphere over there
you're supposed to have these
accountability groups where you get
together and you confess your sins
against marxism
right they would actually have maoist
struggle sessions during time now
where you would do this you'd get up and
you'd confess your sins and you were
forced to do this
and this has been true in every
communist country right paul pott used
to have these things we'd get up
and you confess your sins against
marxism and then you would be punished
for it
and then you would sit back down so they
are now suggesting
that in exactly the same fashion we have
quote unquote accountability groups
if white people get together and call
each other out on their racism
and then presumably forgive each other
and the more you confess the more
praiseworthy you are
the more you say i i this is why you see
rebecca
toperak in this video saying things like
well you know
you almost never finished the work it's
almost impossible to finish the work you
can never get to the end of the work or
kelsey arias saying
i've never even discovered the the depth
of my own racism i was never able to
come up with the depth of my own racism
or at least kennedy saying i have to go
back this is where it starts to get
institutional
we have to go back and we have to see
the way we teach history and we have to
re-teach ourselves history this way
and here you start to see the creep over
from he's sort of personal brow beating
and the self-scourging the 12th century
style self-scourging and and maui style
struggle sessions to
now we have to teach how we how we teach
it we have to change how we teach this
stuff in schools to children
okay let's continue completely through a
white lens
most of us in doing this work have
experienced this where
there's a period of deep shame for being
white
and for acknowledging the harm that our
ancestors have caused
and that's a very legitimate piece of
this work
and we can't ask people of color to hold
our hands
through the shame piece that needs to
happen with other white people
when you do that for one two three four
five years right you end up with
actually a community that is aligned
with each other
in theory that sounds like a good idea
but
i guess i'm curious to hear like what
are some of the pitfalls or risks that
you run if that's the only step you take
the biggest answer is white people don't
really understand racism
and so if i'm relying on other white
people to teach me about racism that can
only go so far
i only best understand racism by talking
to people who are directly
impacted by racism from different
perspectives
so in addition to having white
accountability groups and white
accountability buddies
it's also really important to have
sustained and meaningful
relationships with people of color
okay so this is rebecca toperak and all
the rest of these people suggesting they
can't even understand racism right it's
so deeply rooted in them they feel shame
they feel shame at their own whiteness
so first of all if you feel shame
because of your race
this is racist you should not feel shame
under any circumstances because of a
condition
that you were born into that's insane
okay it's the definition of racism truly
if you feel ashamed because you were
born black we would say oh my god that's
terrible why would you feel ashamed for
being born black
but now the idea is there's something
good about feeling ashamed
for being a white person why did you do
something wrong normally shame attaches
when you do something wrong but the idea
is that by the very color of your skin
you are complicit
in this racist system because the system
benefits you even unconsciously
and so you can't even fight racism right
this goes back to the critical race
theory principles that we were talking
about
right the critical race theory
principles one of them is that white
people can't even properly understand
race
only black people and only hispanic
people and only asian people
and even there is a hierarchy there only
people who are not white can properly
understand racism so now the washington
post says you need to find a black
friend
now recognize that you are all in the
same video they're saying
that if you ask a black person to guide
you on racism this
is in and of itself racist because
you're assuming that that person
has either the wherewithal or the desire
to tell you about racism it's using that
black person as sort of a token to lead
you
but you have to find black friends
because those black friends are the only
ones who are capable of awakening you
to your own racism and to your own
complicity in the system
this is all cultic nonsense it's all
cultic behavior and it's infused
everything
continue i don't have the ability to
like
inherently name things as upholding
white supremacy
or as being racist my whiteness is going
to show up at different points in my
life
and at different points in different
relationships but is it fair
or healthy to be seeking out
relationships with people just to have a
diverse network
because i feel like for people of color
you're kind of constantly
trying to gauge whether or not it's
worth it to be vulnerable or share
how someone hurt you when your white
colleagues or
co-workers or friends mess up there's a
different
cost for my friends of color to be in
relationship with me
so i think one of the things that's
really important is ongoing
being a friend on an ongoing basis for
lots of different things
not just like thinking about racism as a
part of our friendship
when there's something horrible that
happens those relationships
are number one for me to
be there for them as them for me it's a
it's a relationship
and so it should be reciprocal but also
so that i have a broader understanding
of the world
everything i thought about how i existed
in my white body in the world was very
wrong and i needed this new
lens to see the world through
so i think that's been a big piece of my
own work
incredible and nicole ellis is sitting
there but so black people shouldn't be
friends with you because then they're
gonna be used as tokens
and well they won't be used as tokens i
mean we'll still be friends but we'll
kind of use them as tokens but we're
helping to re-examine our own prejudices
and nicole ellis is sitting there like
the judge on high trying to judge all
these white people right i mean that's
that she's there to provide them the
absolution
okay this is racist nonsense it's being
taught to your kids in school it's being
pushed by the washington post
on their front page and the washington
post now the left is angry that you
caught them
okay because here's the reality there's
push back and the pushback is incredibly
serious we're seeing a bevy of states
push actions to ban the teaching of
critical race theory in schools which is
good
okay critical race theory schools have
to decide what they teach to kids they
don't teach kids that two plus two
equals five because that's a waste of
time
stupid counterproductive and illogical
you shouldn't be teaching kids about
racial essentialism you shouldn't be
teaching kids that all the systems of
power in the united states are racist
you shouldn't be teaching kids that by
dint of their very skin color they ought
to feel shame
you shouldn't teach kids false notions
of american history
because that's a garbage thing to do and
you're starting to see blowback on this
and the left which has embraced all of
this right the left loves this stuff
right joe biden's administration agrees
with this washington post video
i dare you to find a single member of
the washing of honestly
of the biden administration who would
dare to say that this video
is the pretentious crappy self-defeating
nonsense that it is you wouldn't find
one person in the entire administration
who would say that not one
so the blow and the blowback is coming
and the blowback is very very real
and the left is very upset about it it
is not a coincidence that the same day
that the washington post
ran this particular video the washington
post also ran
a very long piece being very angry that
anybody
including christopher ruffo who's one of
the people leading the charge has been
fighting back against critical race
theory
and this is precisely the point the left
has been renormalizing america by
pushing radical ideas
slowly into the mainstream by being
intransigent and very very loud
inside specific institutions okay they
push a little bit and then they push a
lot but
they continue to push and they are very
intransigent and they hope that by
bullying you into silence and feel and
making you feel shame for your own race
and making you feel shame for
your own systems and making you feel
shame for america and they can shut you
up and then take over the institutions
and what's happening right now is that
that vast middle is saying no
all it takes to quote-unquote
re-normalize and already re-normalize
institutions is a bunch of people in the
middle saying absolutely not we're not
doing this
and this is why the left is getting
pissed because a bunch of people who are
here too for silent a bunch of people
who are very quiet up to this point
they're now standing up and they're
taking back their school boards they're
standing up and they're retaking their
legislatures they're standing up and
they're retaking congressional seats and
they're saying no
and the left can't handle it because for
a long time 20
of the country has run the other 80
percent of the country and now there's a
vast swath in the middle
who are saying no we're not going to do
this stuff which is phenomenal
and the first step on that is awareness
of the fact that this 20 percent of
people these radicals who have created
this coalition or to push this nonsense
have started to take over the
institutions and in many cases have
already have
have done that you can renormalize as
long as you have a core percentage on
the other side of 20
and the and the 60 in the middle the
unaligned
side with the 20 pushback rather than
the 20 radicals who are pushing this
stuff in the first place that's how
renormalization happens and it's already
happening and it's great to watch and
the left is scared
out of their wits we'll get some more of
this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that thieves
could come after your most valuable
asset
okay the reality is your most valuable
asset is probably your home title that's
pretty much true for everybody
can people actually steal your home
title the answer is yes take it from
this thief who stole over 150 homes and
was sentenced to 25 years in prison this
right here is why you need home title
lock
nobody thinks that i can take their
house and borrow against the house no no
i have title insurance for that
no it's in my name or he would have to
get some special document they would
call me
you know nobody's calling you after i've
stolen the title barred against it or
sold the property or done whatever i've
done with it
it's 60 to 90 days even figure out that
that they're the victim of this crime
you know by that point you start getting
foreclosure notices and you realize
you've got four mortgages on your house
not only that you don't even own your
home anymore it's not even in your name
if you've heard enough you should head
on over to hometitlelock.com register
your address see if you're already a
victim
enter code radio for 30 free days of
protection that is code
radio at home title lock dot com again
that's code radio
at home title lock dot com protect your
most valuable asset
that home title all right we'll get to
more of this in just one second first if
you've been paying attention to the
left's weaponization of the dictionary
you'll notice the accepted language now
changes as quickly
as a car changes lanes history has
demonstrated that when a political party
takes control of the language
things do not end well which is why
michael knowles wrote speechless
controlling words controlling minds in
it
he not only writes words in a book he
also breaks down the history of
political correctness and what the
future will resemble if that is not
stopped so
if you haven't been to the bookstore
lately now is the time speechless will
be available in bookstores tomorrow
tuesday june 22nd that is not all
michael will be doing a live
book signing tomorrow at 7 30 pm eastern
6 30 pm central
at dailywire.com dailywire youtube and
dailywire facebook so
if you want to sign copy just head to
premierecollectables.com
speechless before the signing order one
don't forget to type your question into
the prompter when you check out then
tune in to his live signing and watch to
see if he answers your question during
the live stream if he does not don't
worry you will still get your signed
copy so
get ready for an interesting live stream
some excellent writing and finally an
ability to understand the pc police
better than they understand themselves
which is basically in this day and age
of superpower once again that's
premierecollectables.comspeechless to
get your signed copy tune in tomorrow 7
30 pm eastern
6 30 pm central at dailywire.com youtube
dailywear facebook and watch
michael's live at signing again i'd
never say anything good about michael
moles because not only is that a
principle but it is a truth but
speechless is actually a really good
book and you should get a copy
today also if you've been enjoying
candace's new show as much as you enjoy
the fact that she trends every single
day on twitter i've got some excellent
news for you if you're a daily wear
all-access member you can now be part of
her live studio audience at the daily
wire headquarters in nashville tennessee
if you're lucky
you might be one of the few whose mugs
get seen by all her viewers hurry though
because seating is limited tickets are
sold on a first-come first-served basis
if you live in nashville or
you've been planning on taking a trip
there which is totally worth it
nashville is awesome
now is indeed the time tickets are being
sold for 20 bucks each
head on over to dailywire.com tickets
today
to pick yours up you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all right so the push back to critical
race theory has begun christopher ruffo
is one of the lead researchers on that
particular issue he now works over at
the manhattan institute
and uh and he has a book out coming out
pretty soon
with uh with harper which uh full
disclosure is also my publisher
and he's been pushing into sort of
common parliament's critical race theory
it's been used as the term that was used
before critical race theory was woke-ism
critical race theory is more specific
because it actually goes to the
ideological roots of all of this well
those the the root of the
of the pushback has now created fruit
and you're seeing it
all over right so you're seeing videos
like here's one that went viral of a
father and daughter a black father and
daughter pushing back against critical
race theory it was an excellent video
and the reason it is so telling is
because because critical race theory
suggests that all the systems of america
are deeply racist and inherently
directed at promoting the subservience
of black americans particularly
it means that you're basically saying
black people they have no agency they
have no agency in america in the freest
country in the history of the world
with the richest black families on
planet earth on average
they have no agency whatsoever and so
here is a young black man named corey
yeshua and his six-year-old daughter
royalty
pushing back on critical race theory and
saying this is nonsense and it hurts
black people which it absolutely does
depriving people of agency is the worst
single thing you can do to anyone
in life it is the worst thing when you
tell people they have no agency in their
own life
you cannot do anything worse to a child
than that truly
and when you do when you create actions
that give them no agency obviously that
is an extension of that very idea
anyway here was a corey issue this went
completely viral of course
daddy teaches you can be anything in
this world
that you want to be right don't daddy
teach you that yeah and it doesn't
matter
if you're black or white or any color it
doesn't matter if you're black
white brown yellow right
black and how we treat people is based
on who they are
and not what color they are and if
they're nice and smart
see this is how this is how children
think right here
critical race theory wants to end that
not with my children
it's not going to happen good for him
right so this went viral
there's an illinois dad who got up
recently at a school board hearing
pushing against critical race theory
again black guy
and he said this is this is nonsense he
said color was not discussed
in my home at all
the only race it is the human race i
don't i never raised my sons to see
anybody's color color was never even
discussed in my house at all
all we know is that as much as children
grow they just see other kids and
they'll just immediately start playing
there is no
a child see them like why is this skin
coming like that in mind that we never
discuss that when it all comes down to
it
people are just people my sons never had
to talk about white people all they know
is that they were people they were their
friends they played with them they never
once came home and said dad
my white friend across the street that
they just said my friends
okay and of course this is exactly right
the pushback is happening even
the mainstream media the reason that
they are starting to get so worried
about this and to lie about it
is because they are deeply deeply
worried
that the right is going to be able to
mobilize on this because people in the
middle right that unmotivated 60
in the middle are looking at the left
and saying what you're preaching right
now is cultic crazy garbage that tears
away every system of freedom in the
united states
here's a pbs reporter fully
acknowledging on national tv on sunday
the critical race theory is mobilizing
people as well it should
specific to this idea of critical race
they have to tell you to spend some time
reporting on this county in virginia
about an hour outside of washington
and to your point this is something that
is mobilizing people
and resonating very deeply it was about
a hundred degree day
dozens and dozens and dozens of parents
mostly white in this
largely affluent county showed up to a
school board meeting for many of
the very first school board meeting
they'd ever attended specifically
because of this one
issue okay as well they should the
pushback has begun again if you want to
re-normalize the institutions if you
want to make them normal again
and what you're going to have to do is
stand up and say no and people in the
middle have to be
aware they are aware now they're waking
up to it and they are fighting back and
this scares the living hell out of the
left because this is the first
institutional pushback that we have seen
in america for quite some time
against a systemic motivated left and
it's great
the first thing you got to do is do what
rufo has done and others we've done it
on the show
expose critical race theory for what it
is number two tell people they have to
form coalitions with people who are in
the middle
and that those coalitions have to be
mobilized against this very core
hardened group of people who are pushing
a radical ideology and the institutions
can in fact be taken back i talk about
this in my new book
the authoritarian moment at length
because it's really really important
okay so meanwhile the media is pushing
back on all of this right and they're
telling you lies about all of this
the media have decided that they are
going to simply lie about what critical
race theory is so now because there's a
giant pushback because americans are
pushing back against critical race
theory because finally for the first
time in a very long time you have a
large swath of americans looking
at a movement from the left that's now
been promoted across the military across
your schools
across your your universities and across
your media and in sports and in every
area of your life
because we have noticed it the media has
come up with two areas of pushback
because again they are activists
critical race theory as the founders say
of critical race theory is not merely an
idea
an ideology or philosophy it is in fact
about activism
quote critical race theory contains an
activist dimension it not only tries to
understand our social situation but to
change it
richard delgado gene stefan critical
race theory introduction right this is
their goal is to change things
and many in the media have have drunk
from the well
they've imbibed they're infused with the
spirit of critical race theory so
they've come back with two
angles of pushback angle of pushback
against the pushback number one
is actually actually you just don't know
what critical race theory is and you've
seen this over and over so you saw
mark lamont hill who is a radical idiot
he had on james lindsay and he started
explaining to him well you know let me
let me explain how this really isn't
about gromshi and you haven't read
enough gramsci now let me explain how
it's really not about delgado or stefan
purely it's about various other marxist
thinkers and really has nothing to do
with marxism even though everybody i'm
quoting is a marxist
and everybody's like wow that's he he
knows critical okay i just read you the
tenets of critical race theory
now you know the tenets of critical race
theory they they in their inception were
not vague they've been made deliberately
vague that
who are criticized can then say actually
you don't know
even what you're talking about actually
you've never read any critical race
theory
actually you are just saying something
that is okay so the way this is
broadened out in the public view with
regard to the media
and you have members of the media saying
actually critical race theory is just us
teaching accurate history
accurate history is just critical race
theory okay the answer is no it's not
because critical race theory again
assumes that whiteness is pervasive
everywhere that white supremacy is
pervasive in every institution
and that institutions and principles of
power were created in order
to re-establish and re-enshrine white
supremacy okay that's what critical race
theory says
it's in its f it's founding tenets okay
but what you get is from the media is if
you push back against this
you get the coverage from the washington
post okay here's how the washington post
covers the pushback against critical
race theory quote critical race theory
holds
that racism is systemic in the united
states not just a collection of
individual prejudices an idea that feels
obvious to some
and offensive to others rufus alleged
that efforts to inject awareness of
systemic racism and white privilege
which grew more popular following the
murder of george floyd by police posed
to grave threats to the nation
it's the latest cultural wedge issue
playing out largely but not exclusively
in debate
over schools at its core it pits
progressives who believe white people
should be pushed to confront systemic
racism and white privilege in america
against conservatives who see these
initiatives as painting all
white people as racist again the way
that the washington post is boiling this
down
is that if you believe that there is
racism in america
then this means that you are a critical
race theorist right and and that if you
don't believe that if you believe that
there is no racism in america you're
conservative that of course is a great
simplification
okay this is but this is what cnn's
bakari seller says if you're angry at
critical race theory it's just because
you don't like regular history you don't
want to be taught regular history
here goes with anderson cooper i think
that critical race theory can go by
another name
uh america's history it's amazing that
we're having this discussion where we're
celebrating juneteenth
and now individuals don't want to teach
us what led us up to juneteenth
it's as if we want to keep a secret from
our children that the founders of this
country actually own slaves
um you know at what point will we be
able to teach children that what
happened six years ago yesterday in
charleston south carolina was a white
nationalist who walked into a church and
murdered
nine people i mean that is a part of
america's history
okay i have a question you can teach all
of those things to kids and in fact
every single school child in america
knows those things if they have been
taught history at all in every state in
america
that there was slavery in america and
that many of the founders enslaved yes
we all know that
because that is part of american history
in fact there was a giant you may have
missed it there was a giant civil war
where like hundreds of thousands of
americans died over exactly this
question
and in fact pretty much everybody
understands that a white nationalist
shot up a black church
in south carolina because we're all
alive when that happened
but the basic idea here is that if you
don't push the idea that every
institution in america is rife with
racism and you as a white person don't
properly understand racism
this means that you're just not studying
regular history you get the same thing
from the washington post jonathan k
part i hear he was saying the same thing
people are trying to stop us from
learning history so this is misdirect
number one
is that if you hate racial critical if
you hate critical race theory because
it's garbage
the real thing you're trying to do is
stop people from learning history it's a
lie
the people who are trying to you know
pushing back against quote-unquote
critical race theory which is basically
a blanket way of keeping us from
recognizing talking about and teaching
the fullness
of our history what they're doing is
they're denying the country
it's full it's full retelling the united
states is a
is a great nation and even though people
are trying to keep us
from learning our all of our history ms
oppo lee
showed that it is possible to do things
to make it possible so that the
generations
coming and the generations unborn get to
know their entire history
warts and all okay this is misdirect
number one is the critical race theory
is just history
no it's not the people who literally the
people who wrote critical race theory
say it's not just that right they say
that brown versus board of education for
example
is a racist decision designed to uphold
white supremacy
okay that's what critical race theorist
derek bell says and that's not teaching
history that's teaching garbage okay so
that's misdirect number one is that if
you don't like critical race theory the
push back to the pushback
you don't like critical race theories
because you don't want to study history
then there's pushback number two
pushback number two is that critical
race theory doesn't exist poof
it's in your imagination and if you've
noticed that all the theories of
critical race theory have been
entered into education and if you've
noticed that there are educational
departments that explicitly say
critical race theory is taught if you
notice that they're
they're actual military departments that
talk openly about critical race theory
if you've noticed that robin deangelo is
getting hired by your corporation or ibm
x candy
is being pushed by your corporation or
that on your recommended book list from
your toothbrush company is ibrmx candy
if you've noticed any of this
it's because you're crazy it's all in
your imagination
so chuck todd again this is you cannot
trust your media because they lie to you
because they are part of this
institutional push
here is chuck todd from msnbc saying
critical race theory this is all
creation it's just a creation
let's take this uh this so-called
controversy over critical race theory
and i say so-called controversy because
it's sort of it's a creation that keeps
people watching or keeps people clicking
and suddenly you know yada yada school
board meetings are getting disrupted
right
and you're just sort of like wait a
minute are you covering the news that
people need to know
yes we are you're not you're downplaying
it
basically pretending that none of this
exists
of course it exists it exists in schools
we have private schools teaching we have
public schools teaching it
and your job as the media is to expose
that and you say well that's not
newsworthy you know it's newsworthy
whatever donald trump ate and crapped
out today that's newsworthy
what's truly newsworthy is a theory
we'll go for four years on donald trump
as a russian cat spa but we won't spend
30 seconds
on most school boards in major
metropolitan areas of the united states
have taken up the rubric of anti-racism
which is really just a renaming
of critical race theory that we won't
pay any attention to
okay chris hayes does the same thing on
msnbc he tries to blame the right for
even reacting to critical race theory in
the first place
he had a chiron the other day on msnbc
that is so beyond crazy it's like
he said that the right is fixated on
race we're fixated on race that's all
you guys care about
it's literally all you guys talk about
like 24 hours a day
and when we notice and we push back then
it's oh i can't believe they noticed i
mean like really
look at these people obsessed with the
race here's chris hayes doing this
routine
critical race theory uh as a sort of
technical term is basically a set of
analytic tools that academics
in some fields use starting in law for
studying systematic racism in our
society
the right has rendered the term
meaningless through over deployment
making it into a culture war rallying
cry
since february month over month the
mentions of the term have more than
doubled
entire right-wing media machinery has
become obsessed whipping up a moral
panic
almost entirely among white people that
their children are being taught
toxic truth is about america's long
history of racial oppression hierarchy
okay it's amazing right oh my god
they're mentioning critical race theory
yes we noticed
you mentioned it and we noticed so the
gas lighting is on two levels one is
it's just history no it's not it's an
actual
theory that was meant to be an activist
theory according to his founders
second the lie is that it doesn't exist
it absolutely does exist and it has a
cost
and the cost is that we are not allowed
anymore
according critical race theory to call
out problems as we see them in the
united states whether they are problems
of actual racism
or while they are problems that are not
due to racism but result
in unequal outcome because it turns out
that if you want to prevent unequal
outcome if you would like more equal
outcome
people have to act differently but if
you notice that people have to act
differently
for example you say that crime should be
policed right you should actually spend
time policing crime
rather than suggesting that the cops are
racist this is because you have not
imbibed
from the well of critical race theory
you have not recognized your own white
supremacy you've not recognized that the
police are in fact
a tool of white supremacy in the united
states and the costs of this
are largely borne by black americans not
entirely but largely born by black
americans
yet the same people who are pushing
critical race there are pushing defund
the police because they believe that the
police
are in the words of nicole hannah jones
basically the heirs to the slave
catchers
and so is it any wonder that you see
kids being caught in crossfire in the
bronx
here we have video of kids being caught
in a crossfire in the middle of new york
city
okay this wouldn't have happened even 10
years ago in new york city
when you drink deep from critical race
theory what you end up is with is more
suffering
more inequality more cruelty
more violence and apparently more happy
members of the media
and and the the pushback has begun it
should begin and uh frankly i'm i'm
ecstatic
to see how far the pushback is going at
this point
again mobilize get together with your
friends push back
because the time is now alrighty we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
today he's discussing more on how the
mayor of chicago is declaring racism
a public health crisis you can hear more
details about this story over on
michael's show that is available right
now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam's sci events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
shooting spike in chicago big city
mayors let blm looters off the hook
and juntint replaces the 4th of july
check it out on the michael knowles show